Traductor: Palomita Medina
Revisor: Sebastian Betti
Había una vez un muchachito de tan solo
12 años, que tenía tal pasión
por el conocimiento y aprendizaje
que llegaba a leer dos libros por día.
Ese amor por ese aprendizaje
se desarrolló de una forma tan fuerte
que logró convencer a la biblioteca
de su pueblo para que comprara
nuevos ejemplares de libros
a los que él no tenía acceso.
Fue tan fuerte esa pasión que él tenía,
que le costaba mucho
encontrarse con otros niños
y hablar de los mismos temas.
Por ese motivo, durante toda su vida
sufrió acoso por parte de sus compañeros.
Principalmente, por parte de
adultos que no lo comprendían
y se sentían amenazados.
Uds. estarán pensando que estoy
hablando de mí y no estoy hablando de mí.
Estoy hablando de una persona
muy especial que se llama Elon Musk,
que Uds. seguramente lo conocen;
posiblemente el empresario
más creativo en este momento.
Y el motivo por el cual decidí comenzar
mi charla hablando de él,
mi charla sobre el aprendizaje
como forma de vida, hablando de él,
fue porque unas semanas atrás
mientras me encontraba con mis amigos
con los cuales compartimos
las mismas pasiones,
al llegar a esa reunión yo estaba
tan emocionado que me dijeron:
"¿Qué, es tu cumpleaños? ¿Hoy es Navidad?
¿Qué pasa?"
Y no, es que sucedió un logro tan grande
para todos nosotros, los soñadores,
que lo quiero compartir.
Después de muchos años este joven soñador
al que todo el mundo criticó
y hasta sus propios ídolos
se burlaron de él,
logró crear un vehículo eléctrico,
poner un traje de astronauta ahí.
Y mandarlo a Marte.
Yo les voy a pedir por favor que le demos
un aplauso en este momento.
(Aplausos)
¿Por qué le doy tanto énfasis
a esta imagen?
Porque yo quiero y les voy a pedir
a cada uno de Uds.,
que cada vez que alguien les diga
que no pueden lograr el sueño
que Uds. tienen,
le muestren esta foto.
Como decimos en Argentina
a aquellos boicoteadores de sueños...
Vayan a buscarla al ángulo. Ahí la tienen.
Ahora sí.
Elon me hizo entender
cosas realmente interesantes.
No solo él, sino tantos otros
como Da Vinci y demás...
donde el aprendizaje ya forma parte
de la vida de una persona
desde adentro, desde los principios.
Te define como identidad.
También aprendí,
con el correr de los años,
que ningún éxito es creado como objetivo,
sino que es consecuencia
de una correcta capacitación.
¿Cómo puede ser que todos nosotros
le exijamos a un joven de 16, 17 años
que defina qué va a hacer
el resto de su vida?
¿Por qué no fomentamos que aprendan?
¿Por qué no les creamos la necesidad
y el amor de entender
que aprender es la forma que te genera
la mayor cantidad de libertad en tu vida?
Un generalista, utilizando la definición,
es una persona
que ha logrado obtener
tantos conocimientos simultáneos
que puede generar un impacto exponencial
no solo en su vida,
si no en la de los demás.
En base a ese conocimiento
que yo les estoy transmitiendo,
y seguramente muchos saben,
porque estamos en un TEDx.
voy a arrancar con algo
un poco más sensible,
que es mi propio ejemplo de vida.
Esta imagen que Uds. ven aquí es
un dibujo que yo hice a los siete años.
Desde pequeño yo era súper curioso,
muy tímido, aunque no lo puedan ver ahora
era súper tímido cuando era chico
y me costaba bastante socializar un poco,
porque no entendía cómo las personas
hacían las cosas que hacían.
Pero estoy muy lejos de ser Elon
y no me estoy comparando con el para nada.
Lo único que nos une
es que tenemos dos piernas,
dos ojos, una boca
y un gran amor al aprendizaje.
¿Qué pasó en la vida de este niño
que con siete años
dibujaba y soñaba vivir
en una casa de oro
con los signos de dólares en las ventanas
con una cancha de rugby atrás,
si nunca en mi vida jugué al rugby.
Yo había sido entrenado
para ser un empresario.
Yo creía que el éxito estaba en el dinero.
Inclusive de pequeño.
La cosa es que parte por parte,
día por día, fui aprendiendo cada vez más.
Y fui adquiriendo un amor
que nunca más terminó.
Peor sí se puso en jaque
el día que con once años
--no voy a quebrar-- vino mi madre,
me dio un abrazo...
y yo sentía que algo estaba mal.
A los tres meses de ese abrazo mi madre,
el cáncer la supera, perdón...
Fue un golpe muy fuerte. Obviamente.
Y al año siguiente
también se va mi mejor amigo,
Nicolás Pisciotti, de leucemia.
Imagínense en ese momento,
yo no tenía mas ganas de aprender nada.
Apenas tenía ganas de despertarme.
Eso empezó a crear un montón
de conflictos en mi vida.
A tal punto, que comencé a pensar
qué pasaría con mi hermana menor
si le pasaba algo a mi padre.
Fue por eso que empecé a meterme
en el mundo del emprendedurismo,
del trabajo, y demás.
Con 13 años ya era profesor
de computación de adultos.
Con 15 años tuve mi primer empresa.
Y nunca más dejé de construir cosas.
El destino hizo que comience
a viajar de muy joven
buscando personas iguales a nosotros,
a todos los que estamos en este momento
o viendo este video.
Y fue un camino bastante difícil,
sobre todo, porque a mis 23 años
me llama mi hermana.
Yo estaba viviendo en España.
Tenía tres trabajos, coleccionaba empleos.
Y me dice: "Tenés que volver a Buenos Aires
porque a papá le quedan pocos
meses de vida".
Eso hice. Volví. Me preocupé.
Apoyé a mi padre en todo lo que podía.
Pero también, entendí
el sentido de la libertad.
Entendí que un ser humano
es un animal social
con sentimiento de pertenencia.
Lo repito una vez más: "Un animal
social con sentimiento de pertenencia".
La pertenencia nos define.
Nos hace sentir una identidad.
Y mi identidad era aquel aprendizaje.
Por lo tanto, en honor a mi padre
en aquel momento,
Perdón...
Decidí tomar las riendas de mi vida y
salir a buscar más gente como nosotros.
Tuve el sueño, en ese momento,
de crear una ONG
o ser director de una ONG, a los 40 años.
Tengan cuidado porque
los sueños se cumplen.
Y lo logré con 28 años.
Eso fue un golpe bastante fuerte
porque después ya no sabía qué hacer.
Pero lo más importante,
y a lo que quería llegar con mi mensaje
en este momento,
en la primera parte de la charla,
es que esa ambición, ese amor
por el conocimiento y la curiosidad
no solo me definió
sino que me dio una familia.
Una familia en Emiratos Árabes
me adopta, de corazón.
Musulmanes y yo no soy musulmán.
Y a partir de ese momento me di cuenta
de que yo podía tener una vida también.
Gracias a ellos conocí a mi esposa,
con quien hoy estamos viajando
por el mundo en un coche,
luego de entender
que el objetivo de nuestra vida
es seguir aprendiendo.
Yendo a cada país
y adquiriendo esos conocimientos.
Hay una charla de Peter Diamandis,
que es una charla magistral,
donde él dice que la humanidad
se encuentra en el mejor
momento de su historia.
La tasa de mortalidad infantil
es la más baja desde que tenemos datos.
La esperanza de vida nunca fue más alta.
La medicina preventiva
va a hacer que posiblemente
muchos de los que estamos aquí
vivamos más de 90 años.
La tecnología exponencial
llegó para quedarse
y para brindarnos un montón de
herramientas para poder vivir mejor.
Pero también,
entre conferencia y conferencia,
entre emprendedor y emprendedor,
utilizando esas oportunidades
que esa hambre de conocimiento me dio,
Me di cuenta de una tremenda realidad
que se nos está avecinando.
Y es cómo el impacto de
la tecnología exponencial
va a dejar cientos de millones
de empleos afuera.
Entre ellos, los de la gente que más amo.
Porque yo nací en una clase media,
occidental, latinoamericana, capitalista.
Hay un punto muy importante
con todo esto que estoy hablando
y que tiene que ver con esta diapositiva.
¿Qué va a pasar con América Latina?
Si nosotros seguimos permitiendo
que la corrupción nos quite educación,
nos quite oportunidades
y seguimos permitiendo que
los grandes cerebros de nuestra región
migren y no se queden con nosotros,
podemos ver, si Uds. quieren,
pueden nombrar perfectamente
países que han visto
en nuestra querida región
donde la corrupción ha hecho estragos
y lo sigue haciendo.
Esto a mí me duele profundamente.
Y es el motivo por el cual nosotros decidimos
crear este viaje junto a mi esposa
y viajar por el mundo, dando charlas
conociendo otras personas.
Porque realmente, y aquí
permítanme decir la buena noticia,
porque es muy buena la buena noticia.
Es que la tenemos que entender.
Si nosotros tomamos un planisferio
del mundo vamos a darnos cuenta
de que América Latina específicamente
es una región que tiene
muy baja cantidad de guerras.
Es una región que tiene todos los climas.
Es una región con baja polución.
Miren lo que está sucediendo en Asia
en este momento.
No tenemos prácticamente sobrepoblación.
Yo les confirmo, porque esto lo sé porque
lo hablo con gente de todo el mundo,
que mucha gente quiere venir a vivir
a América Latina.
Cada vez más.
Y por este motivo...
Perdón, me voy a poner un poco
mas pasional en este momento
si no les molesta,
no soy muy de saco.
Todos los que tenemos
acceso a esta charla,
todos los presentes en este momento
aplicaron para estar acá.
Si alguien está viendo este video,
en YouTube o donde sea,
significa que tiene el acceso
a la información que tenemos nosotros.
Yo les quiero decir que
en este momento yo me siento
que soy un niño en una juguetería,
donde puedo tocar
todo lo que está a mi alcance,
y somos todos parte del mismo equipo.
Por este motivo yo les voy a pedir
a cada uno de Uds.,
donde quieran que estén,
no importa, no hay excusas,
que nos pongamos de pie,
literalmente, nos pongamos de pie,
tomemos las riendas de nuestra vida,
entendamos el poder que tenemos
por tener acceso a esta información,
y trabajemos juntos para crear un futuro
donde aquellos que no tienen
la oportunidad
tengan una vida mucho mejor.
Les pido por favor, de todo corazón
que entiendan la importancia
del mensaje que estamos dando,
que entiendan las oportunidades
profundamente que tenemos.
Y sí, es verdad que mucha gente
va a perder su empleo.
Pero de nosotros depende la calidad
de vida que van a tener.
Por una América Latina más unida
y más junta.
Muchas gracias por su tiempo.
(Aplausos)